tiens l'enquète people médiatiser son
couple ruines t-il le couple justement
regarder quand on est amoureux on a
forcément envie de le crier sur tous les
toits et c'est bien naturel
mais lorsqu'on est une star doit-on en
faire de même si beaucoup choisissent de
vivre caché d'autres au contraire
revendiquent leur relation et ça ne
finit pas toujours bien à l'instar de
benjamin pavard héros des huitièmes de
finale de la coupe du monde de football
avec son but magistral un footballeur un
temps en couple avec rachel legrain
trapani miss france 2007
je n'allais pas téléphoner au magazine
people pour leur demander de ne pas
s'intéresser à ma vie privée tout le
monde a été au courant ça m'est revenue
aux oreilles c'est comme ça ça ne m'a
pas plu mais je trouve que j'ai plutôt
bien géré aujourd'hui leur relation est
de l'histoire ancienne tout comme
stéphane bern qui avait choisi de faire
la une de paris match avec son compagnon
lionel une médiatisation qui a mis fin à
leur union
cette couverture a eu un effet que je
n'avais pas escompter ruiné ma vie
privée
c'est violent pour l'autre d'être ainsi
exposés et ces deux exemples sont loin
d'être les seuls parmi les couples
célèbres séparer à cause de la
médiatisation britney spears et charlie
et bersol séparés après huit mois d'un
amour fou guy ritchie et madonna a
divorcé en 2008 après ces temps d'une
relation passionnelle ou encore côté
français julien doré et louise bourgoin
mais aussi joyce jonathan est thomas
hollande le fils de françois alors selon
vous médiatiser son couple quand on est
une star bonne ou mauvaise idée
on parle pas de paparazzade
on parle de tout le pays se sont montrés
tensions socio ça dans la presse et qui
ferment le regretter parce que parce que
ça les a fait ça laisse à ça ça a pété
le couple je ne trouvais pas le mot donc
c'est un peu vulgaire en tout cas ce qui
est sûr c'est que voilà la station de de
benjamin bavard dans le journal du
dimanche je n'ai jamais cherché à mettre
en avant mon image publique me suffit
amplement
je n'ai pas téléphoné magazine people
pour leur demander de ne pas
s'intéresser à ma vie privée tout le
monde était au courant
ça m'est revenue aux oreilles c'est
comme ça ça ne m'a pas plu je trouve que
j'ai plutôt bien géré donc il s'en prend
un petit peu avoue visiblement bas vous
êtes trop mis votre couple en avant
entre la entre les missions les réseaux
sociaux et tout ça et vous lui voulait
une vie plutôt discrète après la coupe
du monde et résultat bat votre couple
n'a pas tenu alors ça me fait énormément
rire quand j'ai vu tous ces articles
parce que forcément ça vous parlez
encore vous l'avais appelé au nom du
tout exploré un non non non nous tes
insultes de toto torre et du compte on a
franchement clairement plus rien à dire
mais rien sexe par téléphone
ces chiffres c'est ça ma fait ça m'a
fait vraiment sourire parce que je vois
ça je dis ok pourtant c'est lui qui
avait voulu que notre couple soit mis
mise en avant mais non avant la coupe du
monde
il faisait exprès de me tacler sur ces
photos dit il mettait sous les photos
instagram dans la chérie avec oui
absolument
voilà presque quand il passe son temps à
regarder des instagram et il voulait
absolument que ça se sache quoi et donc
après une fois qui a été champion du
monde
là il a fait un peu machine arrière en
disant bons voeux tout compte fait tant
qu'il est inconnu surfer sur votre
autorité avant et après donc une journée
compliquée où est la place que vous est
ce que c'est ça en tout cas mais enfin
bref là n'est pas la question
après il dit qu'il veut plus s'exprimer
sur sa vie privée il a quand même
répondu au jdd à une question sur sa vie
privée donc en l'occurrence est avec moi
donc je pense que s'il avait vraiment
pas envie de parler de sa vie privée
il aurait dit ben je ne souhaite pas
m'exprimer à ce sujet et puis bah je
pense aussi qu'ils s'affichent n'a plus
avec des gens connus parce que il joue
qu'il a eu le souci avec moi pourquoi ce
partir en vacances avec des mii ses
influences euse pourquoi invité à son
anniversaire des stars de télé-réalité
et des influenceurs donc pour moi c'est
assez contradictoire pas faux moi j'ai
quelques noms de personnes avec qui
s'amusent et qui fait ce qu'il veut
aller vite mais voilà le bas voilà des
choses des textos pour dire voilà parle
pas comme ça c'est peu mais ce que tu
fais parce que là là on a vu votre
couple me sens pas votre couple dans la
lumière à prendre pour l'a vu naître on
l'a vu exister et maintenant on voit un
peu les voilà et maintenant vous un
petit peu les battles herman aujourd'hui
je suis tellement heureuse que 20 tout
compte fait tant mieux que ça se soit
terminée ceux qui aujourd'hui c'est pas
longtemps le même corps
[Applaudissements]
deux semaines l'ancien sun trois
semaines de transition mois et pardon
mais pas séparées un peu ça le ferait un
petit buzz non alors oui pardon maman
bon ben moi je suis quand même
je suis pour que les stars ne n'expose
pas leur vie privée je préfère m'occuper
nous mêmes justement on avait refusé la
couverture de paris-match l'été lors de
la coupe payante
oui oui très c'était bien mais je compte
vous avait proposé 35 mille euros à 2
way et donc ils avaient bas lui avait
refusé moi je l'avais dit bon quand même
35 milles au oui on voit la muscade et
de là en fait et de là en fait je dis
oui mais tu sais que si on refuse ça on
va être papa radier quand on va partir
en vacances vous mieux donner ce qu'on a
envie de donner bien sûr et il n'a pas
voulu et après ils disent tiens voilà il
ya eu des photos de paparazzi
pendant tout nous va très bien et si on
ouvre un petit peu au cabba la plus
générale général aussi parler avoue
stéphane bern c'est qu'elle fait la une
de paris match et qui dit qu'à cause de
ça son compagnon c-17 pas rendu compte
son compagnon de ce que ça allait
déclencher des airs comme buzz du fait
que dans la rue bah on vous reconnaît
pas tout d'un coup vous reconnaît vous
êtes l'homosexuel vous ai dit que du
coup son couple n'a pas tenu je vous
fasse tilt l'accusé quand on veut piquer
son chien on dit qu'il a la rage c'est
facile de dire que c'est à cause non
mais à cause de paris match qui s'est
séparé maintenant mais c'est sûrement
qu'il est pénible j'en sais rien mais
c'est une sorte de mes vidéos
ces jeux si tous les pauvres couple
david et victoria beckham sa fait 20ans
djezzy et bien c'est ça fait 17 ans je
sais pas vous mais vous c'est que des
couples américain coty qui se montre en
coupe de temps en temps qui pose etc des
power couple comme on dit ça marche
aussi en coupe il faut s'aimer d'abord
et vous pourrez alors c'est renoncer
stéphane bern et son compagnon je pense
que le guen n'est pas le même il sont
homosexuels on sait que c'est plus ni
roland plus dur à supporter et que les
critiques sont probablement extrêmement
douloureuse à supporter quelqu'un qui
n'est pas exposée aurait moins de 50 et
valverde avait un petit peu quand même
hein c'est pas nous ont séparés en deux
car on sait bien que le mot phobie est
encore très présente en france
exploitait sa main fait d'accord pour
les pas des coupes qui s'exposent
excusez moi effectivement tu as raison
c'est pas ça qui capte les pics à dents
cassées coupe c'est n'importe quoi
pouvait pas prétexte
il faut quand même rappeler que la
notoriété quelque chose de pas normal
c'est pas normal dans la classique donc
quand vous êtes un couple qui a vu un
des deux qui ne fait pas un métier
public c'est très compliqué à gérer
évidemment et je vais vous dire les gens
sont jaloux du bonheur des autres c'est
sa part a lieu commun de le dire mais
vaut mieux vivre caché une chanson j'en
rigole
que j'adore vous appelle je ne vous
parlerai pas d'elle est en fait faut
jamais qu'il montre et faites attention
parce qu'au final ça explose forcément
les gens vous envoie des mauvaises c'est
pas une couverture de match le lendemain
la personne va se balader dans la rue
tout le monde ne va pas la reconnaître
est ce qu'aujourd'hui ce jugement parce
que tu as vu c'est ce que ça fait que
dans la presse en permanence où ça
aujourd'hui tutu avec valentin tu l'as
dit vous montrez votre tatouage tu
montre ta vie tu t'exposes elle a été
vue en vacances on t'a vu sur instagram
d'été au lac de beaumont avons entre ce
qu'on a envie de montrer un oui mais la
montre qui montre beaucoup mieux que
vous pourquoi ce besoin encore de rejet
ipad et de recommencer mais pourquoi ce
besoin en permanence d'aller là tout un
week end ça ça me plaît ce bémol j'ai vu
tout s'est tu es tout tout un week-end
sur lac de côme
mais c'est magnifique mais à quel
intérêt si tu es heureuse des tons mais
quel intérêt de passer son temps à
vouloir montrer sa vie à tout le monde
non c'est parce que je reste une fille
normale instagram je vois là comme tout
les monde ont comme nonga combat quand
on met nos vacances sur sur instagram
moi je sais que voilà on est avec
valentin on sait où on sait où on va on
sait ce qu'on voit elle a donc tu sais
que si les paparazzis regarde bas on
sait où on est on sait qu'on sait dans
quel hôtel c'est au secteur en suisse
depuis qu'on a mis son ami ce qu'on
avait envie de oui mais quand même aller
tranquille havre est allé tranquille
parce que en mettant les photos comme ça
pour nous savons qu'au temps de montrer
sur albi j'ai clairement plus envie de
me retrouver seins nus en une deux de
chez pas d'un coup tu veux tessin sera
ta g candidate en maillot de bain très
bien les gens sont contents à la démo je
veux pas ça du tout vous dire un mot
bien non mais c'est vrai que
nous le fait qu'ils aient instagram ça
nous embête beaucoup parce que du coup
ils m'ont tellement de choses sur
instagram qu' on n'a plus vraiment de
raison d'être au bon devant on est
vraiment désolé de 2,2 à ne pas te
laisser notre cellulite les ben on est
vraiment très heureusement il ya des
gens qui ne m'est rien sur instagram et
c'est très bien le mystère parce que la
star doit être mystérieuse exactement
d'accord d'accord mais ça c'est là c'est
une génération nous dit magali que les
vraies stars
ayem balconnet nabi dardanelles tonnerre
sont l'émeute alors je suis désolé c'est
des stars maintenant tu vas leonardo
dicaprio poster des photos de vacances
avec sa mana bat normal qui dit que
l'onu sur un yacht à 50 me de balle les
trois genres et c'est un exemple ou bien
elle l est les grandes stars en général
ne mettent pas leur vie privée alors les
aimer ma mère je trouve que tu le dis
sur instagram je suis pas grâce à son
revêtement j'ai compris mais je parlais
pas debout